人間なら善行為して生まれたということはよく覚えておいてください
我々は別に人間に生まれた人々はね
過去で悪業をして生まれたわけじゃないんです
どんな人間でも たとえ障害を持って生まれても
人間なら善行為の結果なんです
そういうわけで 今今までの説明で
私たちは余計な欲や怒り
憎しみ それからこの欲望を満たすというとんでもない過ちを犯して
この我々の善行為を働かなくなっているんですね
コンピューターが引っかかって止まってるんです
ウイルスが入ってるんです
ですから私たちはこの善行為っていうこと
善行為の結果ですね それはすごく守らなくちゃいけないんです
邪魔してはいけないんです
過去善行為をしたならば
今 前科により幸福になるはずです
私たちは幸福になるはずですよ
そんな運みたいなもんですよ
しかし 悪行為 悪感情 思考のせいで
その成果が現れるのは非常に難しい
我々の頭が悪いんだからね
欲望 悪感情と悪行為もするでしょ
だからこの幸福が現れるのは非常に難しい状態
それでも漏れて漏れて幸福ですよ
皆様の我々の幸福か幸福だと感じているものは
ただ漏れたもんです 本物じゃないんです
今 真面目に真剣に仕事をしていても
その仕事自体が悪行為であるならば
たちまち不幸に陥る 仕事をしたら
稼ぎしたら幸福になるはずですよ
しかし この仕事と稼ぎがまた悪行為だったら
たちまち不幸になっちゃうんですよ
これ法則違反ですよ そんな法則じゃないんです
人間だったら幸福になるはずなんです
陥る すべてを失う可能性は非常に高い
我々の仕事次第に 稼ぎ方次第に幸福が失う可能性っていうのは非常に高い
善行を大事にするべきです
ですから 不幸にならない稼ぎ方
前のことをもうちょこっと説明すると
例えば麻薬を売って金儲かると
まあいくらかはもうすぐ簡単に金が入るんだけど
それまた怠けでしょ 簡単に頭を使わないで
不正で裏金を作ってやるぞとかね
それ悪業ですよ それでは幸せになるはずがないんです
すべて失う可能性っていうのは非常に高い
そういうふうなもので
ですから 欲張って稼いではならない
稼ぐときは金儲かってやるぞとかね
やってはいけません 儲からないんです
怒り 憎しみ 嫉妬で稼いではならない
稼ぐときは 怒り 嫉妬 憎しみなどは割り込まないようにしなくちゃいけない
何の目的も計画もなく
無知で稼いではならない
ただ単に稼いでいるって
それもよくない 仕事は悪行為になってはならない
自分の仕事自体が悪行為
罪になってはならないんです
悪行為といえば 10種類ありますね
嘘をつくこと 窃盗すること
盗むこととかね 正しい仕事は他人の役に立つ行為です
では 正しい仕事っていうのは他人の役に立つんですよ
嘘をついて役に立つわけじゃないでしょ
盗んで金儲けたっても
他人の役に立たないでしょ
それは悪行為なんです
自分も家族も他人も幸福であるようにという念頭で仕事をするんです
念願で 簡単でしょ すっごく簡単ですよ
こんな微妙 仕事をする時は念願があってほしい
私も私の家族も 他の仕事の恩恵を受ける人々みんな
どうかみんな幸せでいてほしい
それだけの考え方で全て好転しますよ
そんな簡単な教えはないんですよ
自画自賛だけですけど
家族理由 生きるため 生きるために
外から体に物質を入れなくてはならない
それが稼ぐ理由なんですよ
外からご飯を入れなくちゃいけないんですよ
肉体維持するために 心の安らぎのために
家族 友人などの人間関係が必要です
食べただけではダメですよ
人間には 心の安らぎも欲しいでしょうに
ですから 家族がいてほしいし
人間関係も欲しいんですよ
そうすると楽しいんです
そのために仕事をするんですよ
稼ぐんですよ 現代では何でも金次第と思っているが
それは社会制度が価値を通貨で公平に判断しようとするからです
経済学者やら社会制度で人間の仕事を品物公平に評価しなくちゃいけないということになって
例えば私はかぼちゃ １個あげたら
相手が米どれぐらい返せばいいかわからないでしょうに
そうすると公平に売買できないんですよ
それで金という数字になってくると
きちんと公平に評価できるんですね
だから現れた金ですよ
みんな間違ってますけど
何でも金次第と言ってます
考えてますけどね 必要なものは揃っている場合は金は要りませんでしょうし
必要な必要なものは全部揃っていると
金が要らなくなっちゃうんですよ
また稼ぎるよ 外の世界だけではなく
自分の体も自分のものではありません
それを覚えておいてください
外の世界 自分のものじゃないでしょ
自分の体もそうなんです
自分のものではありません
自分のものというのは我だけ
体は借りて使うものです
体も借りたもんですよ
体と心の維持管理に必要なものを得る行為は仕事であり
稼ぐことでもある それで借りたものだから
ちゃんとその料金を払わなくちゃいけないし
それから外からご飯からいろんなものをもらいますよ
自分のものじゃないんだから
それ何とかの形で返さなくちゃいけない
自分のものはこうだけです
体も自分のものじゃないんです
だからお金かかりますよ
体の維持管理に 心の維持管理にお金はかかりませんね
自分のものだから すべては無常で変化していくから
仕事稼ぎは絶やすしなくてはならないんです
一回仕事をして それで終わりということはないんです
稼ぐ場合はたまたまありますけど
仕事そうじゃないんですよ
朝ご飯食べたんだから
それで一生いいやということはならないんです
食べても消えていく 体も消えていく
だから消える消えるたびに
また品物を入れなくちゃいけない
入れる品物はまた消えていく
そういうことだから 稼ぎは一時的なものなんですけど
仕事は一生やらなくちゃいけないんです
物を引き寄せる能力はあるのでしょうかと
だから問題は我々に物が必要ですよ
体に 維持するために それから人間関係では人々も必要でしょうし
それもものなんです 家族もものだ
始めるんです で 自分にこの引き寄せる力がなければ
ご飯は自分のところに飛んでくる力がないとどうにもならないんですよ
今風に言えば 金の運がいいとかなんとか言うでしょ
金がなんか自分の方に見て飛んでこないと
その引き寄せる引力のことを考えた方がいいんです
仕事をしただけでは儲からないんですよ
それで稼ぎは良いか悪いかって問題が出てくるんですよ
得るために自分が何かを与えるのでですですね
これ引力のことを説明します
引き寄せる引力というんでしょうかね
財産が自分の方にやってくるのかと
それはすごい大事なポイントなんです
その説明なんです 例えば
我々は何か与える与えてもらうでしょ
持っているものを与えてないものをいただくので
それが仕事ということなんです
稼ぎということなんです
このやり取りがスムースに機能するならば
稼ぎは一生でも悪くないんですね
何か与えたらちゃんと適切なものをもらう
だったら問題ないでしょう
稼ぎはいいんです それからこの公式があります
与えるものは大きくて
得るものは小さいというシステムもあります
与えるものと得るものは等しいという同じということもあります
それは安全な領域ですね
ここら辺 この 2つ与えるはより大きい得るものより
読み方 そういう読み方ですかね
ギビングイズラージャーダン receiving と
まあ私はまあ数学は英語でしか覚えてないんですけど
で この場合は giving is equal to receiving ということで
その 2つはだいたい安全ですよ
問題起こりません たくさん与えているんですけど
たくさんもらってないんです
人生は安全です これが危ないんですよ
与えるものは少ない 得るものは大きい
giving is smaller than receiving ということ
これは危険です 不正です
でもこれ企んでるでしょ
誰でも人間ならちょこっと仕事してたくさんもらおうと
これは違法です 悪行為になります
それから何を与えるんでしょうかということで
人は頭が悪いだけで 与えるものはいくらでも持っているんですよ
ないはずがない 仕事はないはずがないんです
稼げないはずがないんです
業はそれ決まってるんです
死ぬまで生かしてやるぞと
ただ あれは頭が悪くて
私はどんな仕事をすればいいでしょうかとかね
悩んだりするんですよ
通常は体力 技術 能力 知識ですね
与えるものは これは順番に書いてます
一番儲かりやすいのは能力
知識です 体力はそれほど収入がないんです
技術はそれから能力 収入は多いんです
技術あれば能力あればもっと収入が得られます
知識だったらものすごい収入があるんです
収入が大きい分 労働力は減っていくんですよ
体力はほとんど労働力で
どんどん労働力は減っていくんです
才能とは以上のものをいつどこでどのようにするのかと知ることです
この才能 才能というのはこれなんですよ
こんな明確な定義は世の中でないんですよね
だから覚えておいてください
才能っていうのは 自分の体力
技術 能力 知識などは いつどこでどのように与えるのかということ
で 抜群にピッタリするんですよ
When where and how
例えば体力ある when
一番いい時期に与える体力を
儲かるんですよ 体力いらんところ与えたってもね
意味がないんですよ 例えばこちらでこの講演終わったら机片付けなくちゃいけないって
それ体力でしょ それで講演終わった時期
その when ということですね
その時誰かがさっさと片付けてくれると
その人は体力与えてるんですよ
その場合は その仕事をもらった人はあげたい気持ちになっています
本人に引き寄せる引力はついています
そこで体力の持ち主が来て
講演始まる前に全部机をきれいさっぱり片付けてくれるのです
与えるんじゃなくてぶん殴りたくなるでしょ
時期が外れたんですね
だから その場所と時間と
それからどのようにというね
メソッド そのことを知ってるならば
それに才能というんですよ
例えば英語の才能あるというのはおかしいんです
英語の知識 能力ある 英語のことはさっぱりわからない皆様の前でペラペラペラペラペラうるさいだけでしょうに
追い出したくなるんですよ
しかし 皆様 誰かが友達が外国人の人々が来て
それで英語の能力がある人は
さっとその場でビシビシ喋ってくれて
それはそれはありがたいでしょう
だから能力は結構邪魔に
場所が変わったら邪魔なんですよ
才能っていうのは いつどこでどのように自分の能力を使うかという
与えるものを使うかということ
それによって また仏教ではプラスアルファでもっとすごいことを教えてますよ
体 言葉 考えという 3つの行為が他人に対して慈しみであるならば
最大の値です 我々は体で行為する
言葉で喋る 頭で考える
その 3つも生命に対して慈しみである
そうすると無茶引力つくんですよ
そういう人はほんの少々の仕事をしてもたくさん得るんです
これ引力のことで引力がなければもうどうにもならん
品物は寄ってこないんです
これが仏教は明確に発見していってる
あの裏技で 次に真理法を教えることは最小の値です
一番優れている値は真理を教えること
真理を与えることによって
受ける側の一切の苦しみ
悩み 希望 願望なくなり
すべての要求は完了するんです
だからそれほど与えるものっていうのはないんです
一番優れている値は真理を知ることなんです
それでお釈迦様の言葉で言えば
サッブダナンダンマダナンジナティ
意味は 法施は一切の布施に勝すということで
しかし 法施する あるいはできる人には得るべき欲求はほとんどありません
与えるのは何か得たいんだからでしょうし
与えるものの中で最高なものは法を与える
真理を与えることなんですよ
でも 真理を与える人は
もう自分も完了しているんだから
別に外から何もなくても大丈夫です
それから与える行為の分析
よく覚えておいてください
与えるということが引力なんです
それで業に 自分の業に
心にすごい引力ついちゃうんですよ
で それで収入が増えて増えていくんです
人間関係も増えて増えていくんです
家族もすごく穏やかになって
優しくて 自分のことをすごく可愛がって楽しませてくれるんです
それには引力がないと
次にのとこはこの分析ですね
与えるってどういうことかと
与える行為で得る結果が大きいか少ないか考察しなくてはならないんですよ
一応与えるならば できるだけ良い結果を出しましょうという仏教的な考え方だから
ただ仕事をしただけで意味がないんです
結果も最大でなければいけません
結果が大きい方がこのマシンですね
そこでセットA 1 与える能力
たくさんあげられるのに
あげる量は少ない時 結果も少ない
我々に与える能力はいっぱいあるんだけど
与えないんでほんのちょっとだけ
時々いますね みんなもう仕事できるのに嫌だとかね
やりたくないとかね 頼んでもなんかいい加減ちょこちょこっとやってくれるんですよ
その場合は引力なくなっちゃうんですよ
やっぱり自分持ってる能力は思い存分与えなくちゃいけないんですよ
これ お金で言えばわかりやすいんですよ
1万円与えることはできる人がすごくケチって 500円与えると
それで割り当てわかるでしょ
すごい少ないんですね
与えるパーセントは  1万円与える能力がある人は
1万円与えると100パーセント与えているんですよ
寄付の場合は  1万円与えた与えた人がたくさん得を損で 100円あげた人が得が少ないわけじゃありません
100円あげた人は能力はそこだけ出したら
その人も100パーセントあげているんです
1万円寄付する人も 能力はそこまでだったら100パーセントあげてますよ
だから100パーセントあげると100パーセント得る引力ついてるんです
だからだいたいお布施の場合は額は関係ないんだと言ってるのはそういうわけなんです
能力で考えてください
すごい体力ある人は体力あって
もう私はあまりもうもうもう疲れた
疲れるのは嫌やとかね
子供に仕事を任せるとかね
体力ない 自分が黙って
じゃあ君たちやりなさいとかね
そういう場合は 自分が体力
自分持ってるのは与えてないんですよ
2番目 与えるものを得た方法
得た方法も大事なんですよ
正しければ可は大で不正なら可は小です
それはお金でわかりやすい
自分が不正なことをして
麻薬でも売って金儲けて彼は寄付する
でもあの金が汚れてますよ
能力自体が汚れています
そうすると可は小になるんです
それほど引力はつかないんですよ
もう大大スケールでいろんなところに寄付しても
みんな知ってます あいつはね
もういろんな悪いことをしてね
億万長者になっちゃって
今いろいろやってますよと
その罪滅ぼしにとか言うでしょうに
だから引力は少ないんです
だから 与えるものが正しく
自分が得たものでなければいけません
知識などにはあまりそれは機能しないんですよ
知識はカニングして知識を得ることできませんだからね
3番目は与える人の道徳性格
問題です 自分がすごい道徳な人間ならば
性格の素晴らしい人間であるならば
自分が与えるものに結果は大になるんです
道徳的にものすごく悪くて
性格も悪くて そういう人々が良いことをしても
それほど良い引力は強い引力はつかないんです
またあります セクションビー
受ける側から考えると
今セクションで言ったのはあげる側から
それからこの与えるものを受ける側から考えると
１人が受ける恩恵が大きい方が果も大きいんです
で 私は少々のものを与えたんだけど
けど 受ける側にとっては最大の結果になる
ものすごいいい恵みになる
例えば 人が水がなくて脱水状態で死にかけている時
水一杯あげたらその人の命が蘇るでしょうね
だから結果はすごいんです
与えたものと関係なく
恩恵が大きい場合は 自分の行為もすごい大きいんです
受ける生命の数が多い方が果も多いんです
ということは 一人の人に何かあげるよりは
100人にあげた方が当然大きいんですよ
受ける人の数によっても
受ける人は道徳的でない場合は可哀想くない
それで受ける側はものすごい悪人で
もうどうしようもないいい加減な人間だったら
その人を助けてもそれほど結果が多くはならないんです
結果あるんだけど 結果は小になるんです
そこで受ける人は読んでたっけ
受ける人は道徳的である場合は果が大です
本当に立派な方で 性格の素晴らしくて
そういう人を助けると自分の引力が大きくなるんです
かっていうのは この引力のこと
引力が大になるんです
受ける人は完全な人格者の場合は果は最大です
自分が与える 誰かに その人が完全な人格者だったら
自分たちも完全な引力をつけるんですよ
この場合はブッダのことになりますけど
ブッダと阿羅漢たちの場合ですよ
もう完全人格者なんですよ
微塵でも悪いところはないんです
そういう方々に何かちょっとのことを与えたっても
自分が完全に引力 ついてしまうんです
それは与えることの分析
はい それから採算いたとしましょう
そういうやり方でどうやって管理するのかと
ただ お釈迦様の言葉を並べただけで
ちょっと整理はしてないんです
ボーゲーサンハラマナッサバマラッセーバイリーヤトーボーガーサンニチャヤンヤンティーワンミコーウーパチーヤティ
そのゲーですけどね ウタレッシーよ
で 例えば大体お釈迦様時代で四川の中の例ですけどね
財産を稼ぐ時 ミツバチのように行うべきなのですと
ミツバチの生き方してくださいと
儲かる時は白アリの巣のように
その人の財産が増えるのです
白アリは嫌でしょう でも自然の中にいる白アリはすごいアリ塚作るんですよ
こんなちょっとちょっと口で砂を土を練って
口の中に 白アリの口ってのはすごい小さいんですよ
そこでアリ塚作るんですよ
かなりの量になるんですよ
やがて この白アリはもう家に入ったら大迷惑なんですけど
白アリ塚の土はものすごい立派なんですよ
結構粘度粘着力があって
家作ったりする時はすごく役に立つんです
土で壁なんか作ったりすると
あれもうちょこっと練って作れば硬い壁になるんです
で 火事にも大丈夫です
まあもし屋根なんかを火事で消えてしまっても
壁はそのまんまさらに強くなっています
壊れないようにと とにかくこの白アリのアリ塚の大きさでお釈迦様考えてますよ
結構もう時々もうかなりもう白アリが掘ってみたら
これ2倍ぐらいも下の地面の中に土を作ってるんですよ
大量 でも見てみるとなんかもうもういつ頑張っているのかと
増えるのは見えませんよ
知らないうちに増えているんです
稼ぐ時は他人に迷惑をかけたり
迷惑をかけたり 搾取したり
騙したりするのはいけません
咲いた花はミツバチが来るのを待っているのですということで
花が咲いたらミツバチを待ってますよ
蜜持ってってくださいと
そういうふうに稼いでくださいと
だから詐欺をしたり 人を騙したり
金を儲けても相手が嫌がるでしょうに
だからこの 善ベアハウという蜜のことで説明したように
ちゃんとその 3つの条件を見て仕事をすると
相手が自動的に良かったとか助かった助かったとかね
いう気持ちでお金くれるんですよ
芸の続きですね エヴァンボーゲサマハットアラマトクレーギヒチャトゥダーヴィパゲボーゲーエヴァンミッターニガンテティ
このように得た財産を余分に分けるのは好ましい
その人は良い友人関係
人間関係ですねを築く
正しくミツバチのように金儲かる人にとってはいっぱい友達がいるんですよ
だってみんな助けてもらってるんだから
それから財産どうするのかというと
お釈迦様 当時の経済状況に合わせて余分にしてください
収入を エーケーナボーゲーブンジェイアディヒカンマンパヨジェイタトゥッチャンチャニダーペイヤアパダスバイスサティ
エーケーナ 4分の1を使ってくださいと
ちゃんとご飯食べて 家賃を払って
子供たちにもあげてという使う
ドゥイヒカンマンパヨジェイ二分を投資しなさいと
そうするとさらに収入が増えますからね
一文を加えておきなさいと
アパダス何か災難が起きたら
その時使うためにと あの今日あの時間なくて入れるの難しい
忘れちゃったんですけど
調べるとかちょっと時間かかるで
経典を あの仏教は借金は絶対認めません
ローンはものすごい間違いだと
ローンして食べるということは
収入より使っているということなんです
業を壊してます 今ご飯食べる金がない人はお金借りちゃうと明日どうやって払えますかね？今日 1 日分仕事もできなかった人は
明日 2 日分仕事できるはずないでしょ
だから決して収入を超えて使ってはならない
お釈迦様は言うのは 4分の1ぐらい使ってくださいと言っても
現代ではね これはちょっとそれほど収入がないんだからね
数字だけ大きいんだけど
皆様の給料で計算してみてください
給料の 4分の1で家賃も電気電話代全部もう食料全部払っちゃうことできるのかというと
無理かもしれませんね
だからどちらかというと
過去よりは現代の方が貧乏なんですよ
皆様は過去の人よりも我々は豊かというのは
それは俗世間の考え方で
ちゃんとした数学的な科学的な考え方じゃないんです
半分も投資できるならばね
すごい豊かですよ だからまあその通りでなくてもいいんだけど
皆様に覚えてほしいのは
この加えておかなくちゃいけないというポイント
突然病気になったり いろんな出来事が突然起こるんですよ
その時の人に なんとかなんとか助けてちょうだい
助けてちょうだいとかね
泣きながら惨めな思いをするんじゃなくて
大丈夫 もう加えてありましたので
老後のために加えるということは日本の考え方で
あまり仏教的ではないんですよ
なぜならば 死ぬ時まで仕事はありますから
まあ生きていられます
仕事するんだったら稼ぎはしないよ
それから道徳の厳しい仏教だから
年取った親を無視するんだったら
とんでもない悪行為なんですよ
年取れば その分その人々は尊い人間なんです
だから尊敬したりしなくちゃいけないんです
養っていかなくちゃいけないんです
かつて自分も養ってもらったんだから
それでも年取っても仕事はあります
例えば もう体も動かないベッドだけにいるおばあちゃんにしたっても
仕事はありますよ 子供たちやら孫たちやらね
ご飯持ってくる時に祝福ぐらいしてあげれば
どうかお前ももっともっとたくさんもう儲かりますようにとかね
幸せでありますようにとかね
効きますよ そういう祝福は
孫が来てくると まあどうか君の勉強も効きますようにと
私は祝福しました それだけですっごく幸せな気分になりますよ
受ける側は 気分だけじゃないんですよ
そういう場合は本当に幸せになるんです
みんな知らないだけで
そんな単純で生きて幸せに生きていられるということだから
年取ってベッドに至っても仕事はあるんですよ
なんだこれと怒ったりしちゃうと
みんなもう看病したくなくなっちゃうんですよ
そうすると老人ホームに放り込んじゃいますよ
だから人間に仕事は死ぬまでありますので
仏教では老後のために蓄えてくださいということはあまり言わないんです
災難の時 使うために蓄えてくださいと
それは財産の管理 それからこの布施をする
寄付をするという特別な出来事があるんですよ
今まで与える与えるという単語を使ったんですけど
布施をするという言葉もあります
使用する財産の一部を布施寄付として使わなくてはならない
幸福になりたければ リストラになりたくないと思うならば
自分の収入の一部を必ずお布施しますと
寄付しますと 分けてあげなくちゃあかんですよ
そうなるとあの業が壊れないんですよ
新しい善行に入るんだだから
引力っていうのは 一つ引き寄せたら
それで消えちゃうでしょ
でも一部をまた寄付すると
お布施をすると引力は消えないでさらに増えるんです
強くなるんです 仏教の世界では
確実に収入の一部は寄付しなさいという風になっています
だから 布施するということは日常茶飯事の出来事なんです
大体仏教の世界では なんかちょこちょこっと
まあ忙しくて 金がなくてって
もういろいろあってね
もう人生なんかうまくいかないなとか
なんか不幸な出来事 なんとか子供が病気になるとかね
もう仕事でトラブルあるかと思ったら
もうさっさとそういう人々はまあお布施持っていくんですよ
食事とかなんとか作ってお布施をして
それでお坊さんたちに祝福してもらうんです
それうまくいくんですよ
本当にうまくいくんです
なぜならば その人が引力をつけてもらったんです
何の心理もないんです
すごい心理学的なんです
寄付を受ける 受けた人は自分に何も物理的なものを与えないでしょうが
例えばね 恵まれてない人とかね
お坊さんたちとかね 寄付したんだから
お坊さんたちもたくさん何か品物を代わりにはあげませんよ
それはサイキの世界で
こちらは何でしたっけ？あの新年のなんかを持っていくでしょ
あれなんて言いますか
ん？ん？おねおね はい
それでお年玉なんか持っていったら
向こうはやっぱり返してくれるでしょうね
それはサイキの世界で
もう例えば恵まれてない人に何かあげたんだ
その人また何か返してくる
これはありえないんですけど
でもその代わりにすごい引力は自分がついてもらうんです
財産 幸福などを引き寄せる力が自分につくのです
余分に収入が入る人は無駄遣いするのではなく
恵まれない人々を助けるのです
時々業がうまくいって
たっくさん収入がある人がいるんですよ
生まれる時もすごい豊かな家族で生まれて
何の子も知らないで生活して
それで自分もちゃんと仕事をしてとかね
随分金がいっぱいあげもある
その場合も余計な贅沢
無駄遣い ぐちゃぐちゃね
もうスポーツ車は 15台買ったりとかね
あの京都の連中やってるようなね
とんでもない生き方なんですよ
だからイスラム国々としたっても
すっごい貧乏ですごい問題でしょうね
あんな無茶きったなくお金使うんじゃなくて
自分の宗教でも言ってるでしょうに
貧しい人々を助けなさいと
バングラデシュならそういう国々を助けてあげれば
誰も爆弾を落としたり
そんな何の問題もないでしょうね
やり方がまずいんだからね
金銭で無茶 もう無駄に贅沢をする
まあ昨日もテレビ見たんですけど
もう 8台ぐらい もうむちゃ高級車
スポーツ車を持ってる人のこと
1,000万円ぐらいとか
1台とかね そういうあっても乗れないでしょうね
なんか宮殿みたいに家があって
それは自分の家じゃないんだと
お客さんが来るとき接待する家であると
そんなもんで そういうことではなくて
どれほどイスラム人がご飯食べるご飯がなくて
ゴミ箱をあさっているのかというと
自分の宗教の人々でも他宗教の人々を助けてはいけないんですから
その宗教だったら自分の人々を助けを助けてあげたらどうですかと
まあだからこの余計に恵まれてる人々は
その余計な分 自分のものでないと思った方がいいんです
体一個しかないんだからね
これがもう恵まれてない人々に与えて
自分がさらに徳を積まなくちゃいけないんだと
それによりたくさんの善行が蓄積するんです
そういうことで どんどんどんどん幸福になる業が無用に増えていく方法なんです
稼ぎよりも人生の成功
稼ぐことばっかり考えるんじゃなくて
人生を成功してやろうと考えた方がいいんです
長寿 健康 美しさ 高貴な生まれ
収入 生まれ また他の優れたものを期待するものは
善行をすることを怠ってはならないのですというのは
これ文章は難しいのは
このブッダの言葉 もうそのまま訳そうと思ったんです
場所がないんだから偈は入れてないんです
まあ簡単に言えば 人間なら長寿でいたい
健康でいたいと美しくいたいと
生まれるならばすごい高貴なところで
そういう富のいっぱいあるところで生まれたいとかね
例えば政治家になりたくて
政治家に生まれなきゃ日本で無理でしょうね
まあそういうことで まあそう期待はある
他のいろんなものは人間期待する
それだったら欲で期待するんじゃなくて
善行為に怠ってはならない
美しくなりたければ善行為をするんですよ
高いいろんな品物を買って体に塗ったりするんじゃないんです
善行為をすると美しくなるんです
長寿のためにむちゃくちゃあれもこれも食べたりして生活するんじゃなくて
善行為をするんです 智慧のある不放逸の人は
この世で得るべき達するべきものも
あの世で得るべき達するべきものも得るのです
だから不放逸であるならば
智慧もあるんだったら
この人はこの世で得るべきものは全部得るんです
得るんです ということは成功するんです
あの世で死後も達するべきところに行くんです
ということは あの世でも成功するんです
仏教の稼ぎ方は この世で成功するためだけじゃないんです
この世でも幸せで あの世でも幸せでいなきゃ
もうちょっと失敗です
ちょっとのところじゃなくて
結構失敗です その人こそが智慧
理性の人と言える で 偈はディクテーワダンメーヨーチャットヨーチャットサンパライコアッタービサメオディーロパンディトーティパウッチェティ
この世に達するべきものに達する
あの世で達するべきところに達する
そのように意義有意義な生き方をする人のことをパンディト智慧のある人だと言うんだよと
サンユッタニカーヤにあるんです
稼いだものを正しく使用するという
ディーローチャヴィンニューアディガммаボーゲーソーブンジャティキッチャカロウチャホーティソーニャーティサンガンニサボーバリットワアニンドリートサッガムペーティターナン
またサンユッタニカーヤ
直訳します ディーローチャヴィンニュー
まあ頭があるという ヴィンニューっていうのは理性
ディーローっていうのはまあ智慧のあるというね
アディガムボーゲー 財産を獲得して
いっぱい財産をもらって
ソーブンジャティ自分でも楽しみます
財産をよく食べて遊んで
自分も楽しみます キッチャカロウチャホーティ
それからやるべきことも全部やる
ソーニャーティサンガン
親戚をバリットワ バリットワというのは養って
親戚 友達 みんなきちんと養ってあげて
自分でも楽しんでニサ
というのは 牛の王様 リーダーですね
牛の群れっていうのは大体あのボスがいるんですよ
猿の群れも同じで 動物の場合は
牛の場合は大体このボスが面倒見るんですね
行くべきところはちゃんと調べていくし
水飲む川に入る時でも
ボスがちゃんと調べて
自分が先に入って 安全なところで子牛たちとか入るようにしてあげるんです
結構頑張ってますよ 今はなかなか見ることできないんですけどね
昔は野生でいっぱい牛を飼っていた時はよく見られた現象で
まあ現代日本語で言えば親分ですね
親分としてきっちりと生きてるんだと
親族を養う それで非難を受けることなく
死後天に赴くんです それが正しい生き方なんですよ
この世でもよく楽しく生活して
美味しいものを食べて
まあそれなりに楽しんで
気楽に贅沢 まあそれ適度な贅沢もして
それから自分の周りの人々も助けて養ってあげて
家族やらね 死ぬ時でも天国に行く
文句はないでしょ そういう人生は
化石は自分から逃げる
これもブッダの言葉です
穀物 財産 金銀 宝石 他の道具
他の必要な道具ですね
使用人 自分に従う人々
そのすべてを置いておいて去るのです
それ死っていうことなんです
いくら品物があっても
いくら人間関係あっても
死ぬ時は自分一人で死ななくちゃいけない
すべて去っていかなくちゃいけないと
このサンユッタニカーに書いているんです
それで次の偈にこう書いています
体言葉思考によって行った行為のみが死後影のようについてくるんです
自分が体で言葉で考えることで行った行為だけは自分から逃げません
行為は業だからね 業はポテンシャルで残るんだから
体も借りたもんでしょ
置いておくんです 家も外からもらったもんでしょ
それは置いておくんです
家族も外からもらったもんだから置いておくんです
死ぬ時は自分の行為の結果だけ持ってくる
それだけ自分のものなんです
したがって 死後も実る善行為をした方が良いかな
死後も実る  死んでからも幸福になるように
我々は今生きていかなくちゃいけないんです
だから 生きる場合はいつでも善行為善行為しなくちゃ
正解しなくちゃいけない
小さな悪行為でもしてはならないと
それは業の法則からお釈迦様に説かれているんです
あの世に行く人に 功徳がだけが支えになる
あの世に行く時は 支えになる
助けてくれるのは功徳だけ
善行為だけ 功徳というのは善行為ですよ
プンニャーニパラロカスインパティッターホンティパーニナ
これはだいたい仏教の人々は暗記しています
この偈は そうすると結構頑張れるんです
死ぬ時は善行為だけよと
子供も孫も助けにならんぞと
サンユッタニカーにあるんです
それがこの 人生は稼ぐんじゃなくて成功するんだということです
で 財産は逃げるもんですよ
子供も家族もみんな自分から逃げるというか
自分が逃げるかどちらかわからないんだけど
どちらでも置きますからね
自分から逃げないのは自分の行為だけ
富豪かで悪いのということで
欲執着は悪だ悪だとするが
富豪であることは悪ではありません
今までの説明でわかるでしょう
いくら富を得たって別に抜け目ありません
それは悪ではありません
過去善行を行ったものなら
富は勝手に付いてくるんですからね
過去世でいいことをしておいたならば
もう嫌でももう富がついてくるんですよ
それで我々も自分の業を壊してないならば
もう富が勝手に付いてくるんです
しかし それに執着したり
傲慢になったり 贅沢に陥って罪を犯したりすると
後は怖いんです 富がいっぱいあるのは悪じゃないんだけど
この富をどう使うのかと
それによって後は危ないんです
だからあまり贅沢に陥らないで
贅沢をしてもいいんだけど
贅沢するところで悪いことしてるでしょ
悪行為してる それやめてほしい
余分な財産を恵まれない人を助けるために
人格を向上させるために
心性を広げるために据やすんです
もし余分な財産があったら
これは人格向上のために据やすんですよ
例えばブッダの時代で
このすごい金持ちがいっぱい仏教徒になったんですよ
ウィサーカー夫人 アーナンダピンデリコ氏
もう出てくる出てくる最近の名前がっていうのはほとんどもう大富豪家なんですよ
商人たちで その人々は財産は罪だ
悪だとかね 執着捨てるとか
ブッダから教えている
もうもうそう言ったら寄ってくるはずないでしょうに
財産が悪じゃない その財産をどのように使うかっていうことで
問題は決めます 決めますよということで
みんな何をしたかというと
この全部もうブッダの教えを広めるために寄付をしたり
お寺を作ってあげたりして
インド全体的にサービスしてあげたんですよ
だから そういう遠い昔のその方々のお陰で今の仏教があるんですよ
アナータピンデリコ氏のウィサーカー夫人のお陰で
いまだに仏教は生きているんです
だからその財産 財産いまだに生きているんですよ
すごいことです だから
たくさん富がある人は
そういうすごい目的でそれを使っちゃうと
もう人間というよりものすごい人間乗り越えてますよ
終わり そういうことで
加速論理は終了いたします
ありがとうございます